humans dream about leaving Earth and
traveling through the galaxy but we were
born too early to be part of it or were
we the reality is we could begin our
dream by building a moon base today we
actually do have the technology and
current estimates from NASA and the
private sector say it could be done for
twenty to forty billion dollars spread
out over about a decade the price is
comparable to the International Space
Station or the budget surplus of Germany
in 2017 not that big an investment
really the payoff would be immeasurable
the moon is a sandbox to develop new
technologies and exploit unlimited
resources it would start a new space
race and lay the foundation for us to
spread out into the solar system and
beyond
it would create a vast array of new
technologies to benefit us on earth and
we would all be part of it so why are we
doing it well sadly it's hard to get
governments interested in long-term
investments in the future of humanity
let's imagine just doing it if we start
today how would we build a moon base
[Music]
throughout history colonization happened
in phases in the first phase of the age
of expiration of the new world for
example European monarchs funded
expeditions to chart and discover and to
stake their claims they planted a flag
and set up a camp but they didn't stay
in the second phase small missions set
up outposts and settlements were founded
which was still very dependent on their
home countries for supplies some failed
but others survived and established a
permanent presence only then in the
third phase did a true colony form to
which tradesmen and laborers could
emigrate creating new wealth and
opportunities for themselves and their
families
sending extreme wealth back to their
countries of origin when we colonized
the moon we'll go through the same three
phases this time without murdering
billions of innocent people in the
process the moon is not a welcoming
place for living things a moon day lasts
29 Earth days with a difference of maybe
300 degrees Celsius between sunlight and
shade there's no atmosphere to shield us
from meteorites big and small or cosmic
radiation were still the lunar surface
is covered in a layer of nasty jagged
dust the moon is hard but we're good at
doing hard things in the first phase of
lunar colonization our explorers proved
it can be done that a new world can be
reached this face started 60 years ago
with the Apollo missions since then
satellites like the American Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter have mapped the
moon while Rovers like the Chinese you
too have studied the composition of the
lunar surface looking for water ice and
metals face one is more or less complete
we know what we need to know to enter
phase two in the second phase
astronauts will build the first moon
base and this could begin today
the first small new bass could be
completed in a decade the first nation
that establishes this base will be akin
to the first nations building outposts
in the new world 500 years ago it's
expensive to send rockets to the moon so
we will send as little as possible the
base will be light little more than
inflatable habitats for crews of no more
than 12 and will be deployed somewhere
with a natural shelter options include
caves like underground lava tube tunnels
or craters near the poles where the days
are six months long these astronauts
will not stay long the habitat is likely
to be abandoned between missions as
solar panels cannot generate electricity
during the lunar night
but they'll do the groundwork to enable
humans to stay permanently our first
crew will consist of scientists and
engineers who will study the composition
of the moon and whose experiments will
explore ways of using the available
lunar material say purifying a lunar ice
and turning it into water for human use
and water is important for far more than
drinking they can use it to experiment
with growing plants for food hydrogen
fuel cells will store power through the
long night extending astronaut stays and
most importantly it could be split into
hydrogen and oxygen rocket fuel by
harvesting water from the moon and
putting it into orbit the moon base will
supply an orbital depot where scientific
missions to Mars and the outer solar
system can refuel compared to the earth
it's much easier and cheaper to get
things off the moon into orbit
colonizing Mars may mean starting from
the moon
but this isn't a true colony not yet the
base will be abandoned if funding stops
if we want our base to grow into the
third phase into a true colony it must
become self-sufficient supporting itself
via exports to earth now private
contractors arrive looking to get rich
off lunar resources and support services
if it's cheaper to produce rocket fuel
in space what else can they get rich on
they could extract precious metals
abundant in impact craters and other raw
materials from the lunar regolith one
promising possibility is the mining of
helium-3 an isotope that could one day
be used in nuclear fusion reactors
something the Chinese lunar exploration
program is currently looking into future
colonists may export helium-3 back to
earth
providing us with cheap and clean fusion
energy asteroids could be pulled into
the moon's orbit and mined with
commercial exports to earth the colony
is fully in its third phase
self-sufficient and economically
productive our base will begin using
lunar material in its construction
projects if it's to continue growing
fortunately lunar soil has all the
necessary ingredients to make concrete
robotic mining rigs can sift the lunar
dust for organic molecules and could be
used to build huge structures way too
massive to be brought from Earth while
advances in 3d printing will make it
possible to produce almost everything
else the truths need it's hard to say
when exactly if the colony becomes
self-sustaining
growth is gradual experiments are
replaced by industry and the population
steadily reaches the hundreds
encompassing more than just scientists
engineers pilots and contractors
representing countries and corporations
will be present two of these people will
make a breakthrough not scientific but
social they will have the first
extraterrestrial child throughout
history the birth of the first child was
celebrated as a moment where the seed of
a colony finally and irreversibly took
root here it means that the moon is not
just a place for scientists and
engineers to work it's a place for
people to live to raise a family
once this transition happens the colony
grows rapidly building more habitats and
schools and farms and all the things
needed to support the growing population
as our colony grows all kinds of new
technologies will be invented to sustain
it they might develop crops that
efficiently recycle carbon dioxide or
the grow with very little water they
might find ways to recycle and reuse
100% of that waste technologies that are
extremely valuable for Earth they could
even build the first space elevator in
the solar system with a space elevator
spacecraft astronauts and raw materials
could be brought back and forth from
lunar orbit without needing to use
rockets at all the moon may become a hub
for economic activity on a scale that's
hard to imagine right now
it's hard to say who will own the colony
at this point will the first person ball
on the moon take the national identity
of their parents or will a new
generation melt together into a new
lunar society and when existing treaties
that bar any nation from owning the moon
are inevitably rewritten will the
colonists be given a say will they
declare independence from the earth
however it happens the moon is a perfect
sandbox to learn how to colonize the
solar system the perfect project to
unify Nations and the only way to
guarantee our survival as a species
should something tragic happen on earth
if we ever want to colonize the Milky
Way we'll have to start somewhere so why
not start there why not start now
[Music]
while unfortunately you can't jump on a
spacecraft and go to the moon right now
you can learn more interesting things
about space and our universe and we can
even help you with that
Kurt schizont and brilliant are
collaborating on a six-part video series
about our favorite science and space
topics courtesans has worked with
brilliant for a while now and we've
loved what they're doing in a nutshell
brilliant teaches you science and maths
with a hands-on approach by solving
puzzles yourself you learn to understand
concepts instead of just memorizing
facts if you'd like to think more like a
scientist go to brilliant org slash
nutshell and sign up for free the first
698 people to use the link at their
annual premium membership at a 20%
discount and also support our
collaboration with brilliant
[Music]